I'm not just going to review a couple
more projectile motion problems because
I really want you to understand this as
deeply as possible because the rest of
physics that we do at the rest of
mechanics it a lot of it really just
depends on your understanding of
projectile motions and I and and
hopefully this will be intuitive for you
after some point so let's just go back
to a problem we did before let's say
that I'm at the top of a building and I
take a rock or a ball and I don't
recommend that you do this and I drop it
I dropped the ball and let's say that I
know that the building that the height
so that the building is well I don't
know let's let's say it's a very tall
building let's say it's well it's not
let's not let's say it's not too tall
let's say this we're throwing it from
the 10th story so it's roughly a hundred
feet or that's about thirty meters right
thirty meters so the ball is gonna go
thirty meters down so the change in
distance the change in distance is gonna
be minus thirty meters right the ball is
gonna fall thirty meters now if I ask
you hey how you how fast is that ball
gonna be when it's when it right before
it hits the ground well there's there's
two you know I could rewrite all the
formulas but I think hopefully you know
by now but there's there's two kind of
interesting formulas we might use and I
also show you maybe how to do this more
intuitively but there's VF squared is
equal to VI squared plus two ad and then
there is and this is two times Delta D
right whoops it's two plus two a times
change in distance sometimes we'll just
write that as distance and then there
was change in distance is equal to the
initial velocity times time plus
acceleration times squared over two
right and then there was the other ones
you know change in distance is rate
times time and velocity is changing its
acceleration times time and you know
about all a velocity etcetera etc so one
of these formulas I think might strike
you as immediately useful to what we're
trying to figure out because we're
trying to figure out what the velocity
is when you hit the ground right we want
to know what the final velocity is we
know the initial velocity the initial
velocity is zero right we're just
letting it go and then what's what's the
acceleration where the acceleration is
the acceleration is is gravity which is
equal to minus ten meters per second
squared
so we could use this formula because we
know V I we know acceleration we know
change in distance so we could solve fer
for for velocity so we get V F squared
is equal to vi squared well that's just
zero right times two acceleration so
that's minus 10 and then what's what's
the distance well the distance is minus
30 right change in distance is minus 30
so you get VF squared is equal to well
so 10 times 30 is 300 is equal to 600 we
know let's see so if I took 600 square
root so 24 roughly 24 point five meters
per second so VF is equal to twenty four
point five approximately approximately
equal to twenty four point five meters
per second now if we wanted to know well
how long did it take the thing to to to
hit the ground or how long should it
take the thing to hit the ground well
that we could use this formula right
because we know the change in distance
we know the initial velocity is zero we
know the acceleration so we could just
solve for T so change in distance I said
was - 30 - 30 right though the ball went
down 30 meters we could say minus 30
remember
see I wanna let me change the colors cuz
I wanna make sure you know which formula
I'm using so I'll do in that color minus
30 is equal to the initial velocity is
zero so the initial velocity times
anything is here so this term cancels
out plus eighty squared over two so
what's a a is minus ten minus 10 divided
by 2 is minus five so it's minus 5t
squared and so you divide both sides by
five and you get T squared is equal to
six once again use the trusty calculator
the square root of six is roughly two
point four five seconds t is equal to
two point four five seconds pre-need
using these two formulas in about three
minutes we were and we probably do it
faster if we weren't explaining it so
you could do it really fast one in an
exam you know I just said I drop a ball
from a building that's that's the one I
say thirty meters high now very quickly
we were able to figure out how fast it
was falling when it when it hit the
ground and how long should it take for
it to fall and if I were to give you one
of the other pieces of information if I
told you that the ball took two point
four five seconds to fall and I didn't
tell you the distance then you could
have figured out the distance based on
that information using the same formula
so hopefully hopefully that that that
makes that makes some sense so let me do
actually I'll leave it there right now I
just wanted to show you that when you
actually just go straight to the
formulas and you don't do all of the
kind of meandering explanations that I
tend to do which I do for a reason I do
them to give you an intuition but when
you just go straight to the formulas
these equations these problems don't
don't really take much time but with
that said let me show you how to do it
intuitively if you forget if you forget
the formulas so once again I'm dropping
a ball it's a 30 meter building right
and I want to figure out how what the
speed is when it hits and how long did
it take
well let's just start with our basics
let's say I just had em Nisha and the
only thing I remember is change in
distance change in distance is equal to
rate times time
or average rate or average velocity
times time and I know that change in
velocity change in velocity is equal to
this to acceleration times time if I say
and if I if I know that my acceleration
is constant otherwise it'd be kind of
the the average acceleration but this is
all you have to know and I'm gonna show
you right now so we know what the change
in distance is right the change in
distance and just so not to confusion
we're doing the exact same problem but
I'm just showing you that you didn't
have to memorize the formulas although
it might be faster if you do so the
change in distance is minus 30 meters
all right so let's plug that in straight
so we know that minus 30 meters this is
this is what I'm gonna use minus 30
meters is equal to the average velocity
times time all right well what's the
what's the average velocity let's see if
we can figure that out well we know the
average velocity is just the average of
the initial and the final velocity well
what's the what's the initial velocity
well the initial velocity is zero VI is
zero the final velocity is well it's the
final velocity we don't know that yet so
what's the average velocity going to be
it's gonna be the average of these two
numbers so the average velocity is gonna
be this is a little too bloody I don't
like this color the average velocity is
gonna be the final velocity plus the
initial velocity over two which equals
EF over to right so let's let's put that
into into our formula so minus 30 is
equal to the average velocity is just
the final velocity divided by two times
time and now you see but but Sal we
still have two variables we can't solve
for either one of them right well if we
could write time if we could write time
in in terms of final velocity then we
could solve for final velocity so let's
try doing that
so let's use let's use this equation
right there change in velocity is equal
to acceleration times time what's the
change in velocity it's the final
velocity minus the initial velocity and
that equals acceleration acceleration is
minus 10 meters per second squared times
time and what's the initial velocity
that's zero right so we know that VF
this is zero is equal to minus 10 T and
if we wanted to write the other way we
could say T is equal to minus VF over
ten all right I just rearranged this
equation now I could take this and
substitute it back into this equation
and I get minus 30 is equal to VF over 2
times T which is this right here
so times minus VF over ten and if you
solve this you get minus VF well you get
minus VF you get well you essentially
get the exact thing same thing we got in
the previous problem you get a VF
squared is equal to 600 I'm skipping
some steps just because I'm running out
of time and you get the same answer
whatever twenty four point five seconds
I just wanted to do that too because I
want to show you you really just have to
memorize these two things and then you
can derive all those equations on the
fly although it can be faster to know
them at a time but but this is these are
the only two things that were ever
really using those other equations are
just derivation of them I'll see you in
the next presentation